even among as diverse a group as
president joe biden's cabinet interior
secretary deb holland's path to office
is extraordinary
she raised a child as a single mother
lived off food stamps and even
experienced homelessness
now she is the country's first native
american cabinet member
today forbes estimates holland's
personal net worth at zero dollars based
on a review of her financial disclosure
in public records
federal appointees and officials are
required to list nearly all assets
liabilities and sources of income on
disclosure reports
in her december 2020 filing the interior
secretary listed only two items
student loans worth no more than fifty
thousand dollars and a 175 dollar annual
tribal payment
filers are not expected to disclose the
value of any personal residence they own
but forbes could not find any record
that holland owns a house
voter registration records show that she
and her partner live in a new mexico
home worth more than 1 million dollars
but holland doesn't own the property
filers can also omit the value of their
thrift savings plans or any cash account
with less than 5 000
holland is a member of the pueblo of
laguna and a 35th generation new mexican
her parents were in the marines and navy
and she spent her childhood traveling
between military bases
in 1994 holland got her bachelor's
degree from the university of new mexico
and gave birth to her only child
she also started and ran her own
business called pueblo salsa which
sourced local ingredients and sold to
grocery stores and mom and pop shops
holland sold her business to attend law
school at the university of new mexico
where she graduated in 2006.
in addition to studying she worked on
legislation at the new mexico state
house where she got involved in passing
a law to provide in-state college
tuition to members of american indian
nations
after graduation holland got involved in
politics serving as delegate to the
democratic national convention in 2008
and later becoming chair of the new
mexico state democratic party
she also had leadership roles as a san
felipe pueblo tribal administrator and
on the board for the laguna development
corps a pueblo of laguna owned business
that manages casinos and retail
operations
in 2014 holland ran for office as
lieutenant governor new mexico
she lost but that didn't stop her from
announcing her candidacy for the u.s
house of representatives in 2017.
this time she won becoming one of the
first two native american women to ever
be elected to congress and getting a
major pay raise in the process
the year before her campaign financial
disclosure reports show that she had an
income of about 41 thousand dollars
9 000 of which came from the state of
new mexico for unemployment
in her first year in the house her
income shot up to one hundred and
seventy four thousand dollars
now as cabinet secretary holland's
annual salary exceeds two hundred
thousand dollars
a sum that could allow her to pay off
the remaining student loan debt soon
enough
[Music]
you